right uh the
uh miami dolphins we talked about this a
little bit during the show they have two
quarterbacks they're trying to figure
out who the starter is going to be many
assume josh rosen would easily beat out
ryan fitzpatrick so far fitzpatrick is
the better of the two coach brian flores
pointed that out to reporters on tuesday
and something that i threw out there at
the end of our discussion chris i want
to build on that and elaborate on that a
little bit and get your thoughts some
more on it
how much of this is a test by the
dolphins of josh rosen's ability to deal
with the adversity that comes from not
being the number one quarterback not
being the guy not being the smartest guy
in the room because of the presence of
the harvard educated ryan fitzpatrick is
this all part of an effort to see how he
handles
being in a situation where things aren't
as easy for him as he thought they were
going to be i don't think you're far you
know far off there mike you know i don't
know if there was like an intentional oh
let's start ryan fitzpatrick just to see
how rosen you know reacts to it but i
just knowing that group there in miami
i'm sure this is one of the things they
wanted to see josh rosen handle anyways
which was some adversity things aren't
going good we're going to talk about the
other guy you know how does he handle
that those are those are some of the
things that everybody questioned about
josh rosen a little bit coming out in
the draft now he handles his rookie
season with the arizona cardinals very
well and even last off-season with the
draft and the kyla murray talk he really
did a phenomenal job there other than
maybe unfollowing the cardinals the
night of the draft as soon as they
picked kyler murray that might have been
a hair petty if we're going to be
nitpicky and things like that but uh you
know one thing from the new england
regime of coaches and it goes back to
bill parcells and when bill belichick
was coaching with the giants under
parcells and my dad was a quarterback
and all that they they want you know
that i always kind of bumble this phrase
but they want their they want their
their their quarterback to be a sergeant
or a a a commander not you know not the
uh what do i want to say the cruise ship
you know commandeer who's just showing
everybody they want a guy that's battle
tested tough mentally can handle the
offense do all those things and they're
going to find that out with josh rosen
as this situation plays out
yeah and look they've got three years
and a little over six million dollars in
total compensation they can they can
take their time and see what they have
but there is going to be some urgency
because there's a belief that the
dolphins don't perform well this year
next year is the year to look into
drafting a guy who has developed into
their franchise quarterback and this is
a team now that's 20 years removed from
dan marino and they've yet to find that
true year in and year out franchise
quarterback they gave ryan tannehill a
long time to show whether or not he
could be a franchise guy i don't know
that josh rosen is going to have that
same luxury and the sooner he gets on
the field the sooner they're going to
find out what kind of a player he is but
in the interim they're going to find out
what kind of a guy he is yeah if he has
to deal with being second fiddle to ryan
fitzpatrick
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports